Cette théorie, sans aucun doute le chef-d'œuvre d'Einstein,
révèle le fonctionnement de l'univers aux plus grandes échelles,
et condense en une élégante équation
aussi bien la chute des pommes que l'avènement du temps et de l'espace.
1915 devait être une année passionnante pour les physiciens.
Deux nouvelles idées étaient en train de révolutionner le domaine.
L'une était la relativité d'Einstein,
l'autre était peut-être encore plus révolutionnaire :
la mécanique quantique,
une nouvelle façon très étrange mais extrêmement efficace
de comprendre le monde des atomes et des particules.
Au cours du siècle dernier, ces deux idées ont radicalement transformé
notre vision de l'univers.
Grâce à la relativité et la mécanique quantique,
nous avons découvert de quoi est fait l'univers,
comment il a commencé et comment il évolue encore.
Cent ans plus tard, nous arrivons à un nouveau tournant de la physique,
mais les enjeux sont à présent différents.
Dans les prochaines années, nous saurons peut-être
si nous pouvons encore repousser la frontière de l'inconnu,
ou si, pour la première fois dans l'histoire des sciences,
nous serons face à des questions auxquelles nous ne pouvons pas répondre,
non par manque d'intelligence ou de technologie,
mais parce que la physique elle-même nous en empêche.
Voici le problème fondamental : l'univers est trop, bien trop intéressant.
Selon la relativité et la mécanique quantique,
l'univers devrait être morne.
Il devrait être sombre, mortel, sans vie.
Mais en l'observant, nous voyons qu'il regorge de choses intéressantes,
d'étoiles, de planètes, d'arbres, d'écureuils.
La vraie question est, donc,
pourquoi est-ce que tout cela existe ?
Pourquoi quelque chose plutôt que rien ?
Cette contradiction est au cœur de la physique fondamentale,
et les années à venir pourraient nous dire s'il sera un jour possible de la résoudre.
Au centre de ce problème se trouvent deux valeurs,
deux valeurs hautement dangereuses.
Il s'agit de propriétés mesurables de l'univers,
et elles sont dangereuses car,
si elles étaient différentes, même rien qu'un peu,
notre univers tel que nous le connaissons n'existerait pas.
La première valeur est liée à la découverte faite
à quelques kms d'ici, au CERN, où se trouve cette machine,
le plus grand outil scientifique jamais construit par l'homme,
le Large Hadron Collider.
Il accélère des particules subatomiques le long d'un anneau de 27 kilomètres,
se rapprochant de la vitesse de la lumière
avant de les faire entrer en collision dans d'immenses détecteurs de particules.
Le 4 juillet 2012, des physiciens du CERN ont annoncé au monde
la découverte d'une nouvelle particule fondamentale
créée par les violentes collisions au sein du LHC : le boson de Higgs.
Si vous suiviez l'actualité de l'époque,
vous avez certainement remarqué l'enthousiasme des physiciens,
et vous avez peut-être pensé
que nous nous emballons à chaque nouvelle particule.
Et, c'est un peu vrai,
mais le boson de Higgs est vraiment spécial.
Nous étions très excités car cette découverte
prouve l'existence d'un champ de force cosmique.
Vous ne voyez peut-être pas ce qu'est un champ de force,
mais vous en connaissez un.
Si vous avez approché un aimant d'un objet métallique
et senti l'attraction entre les deux,
vous avez senti l'effet d'un champ.
Le champ de Higgs est un peu comme un champ magnétique,
sauf qu'il a une valeur constante partout.
Il nous entoure en ce moment.
On ne peut ni le voir ni le toucher,
mais sans lui,
nous n'existerions pas.
Ce champ donne leur masse
aux particules fondamentales qui nous composent.
Sans lui, ces particules n'auraient aucune masse,
aucun atome ne se formerait, et nous ne serions pas là.
Mais un grand mystère entoure le champ de Higgs.
Selon la relativité et la mécanique quantique, il devrait
fonctionner comme un interrupteur.
Il serait soit inactif,
avec une valeur nulle partout dans l'espace,
soit actif avec une valeur gigantesque.
Dans les deux cas, les atomes n'existeraient pas,
et donc toutes ces choses passionnantes
ne pourraient pas exister non plus.
En réalité, le champ de Higgs est juste un peu actif,
pas zéro mais dix millions de milliards de fois plus faible que sa valeur maximale,
comme un interrupteur bloqué à la limite de la position éteinte.
Et cette valeur est cruciale.
Si elle était légèrement différente,
l'univers n'aurait aucune structure physique.
C'est donc la première valeur dangereuse,
l'intensité du champ de Higgs.
Des théoriciens cherchent depuis des décennies
la raison de cette valeur étrangement précise,
et ont imaginé de nombreuses explications.
Celles-ci ont des noms exotiques comme « supersymétrie » ou
« grandes dimensions supplémentaires. »
Je vous épargne les détails,
mais voici le plus important :
chacune de ces théories implique des nouvelles particules
que nous devrions détecter au LHC
en même temps que le boson de Higgs.
Mais il n'y a pour l'instant aucun signe de ces particules.
Mais il y a un exemple encore pire
de valeur aussi précise que dangereuse,
et à l'inverse du champ de Higgs,
il vient de l'étude de l'univers aux plus grandes échelles.
Une des plus grandes conséquences de la relativité générale
fut la découverte que l'univers commença par une expansion du temps et de l'espace
il y a 13,8 milliards d'années : le Big Bang.
Selon les premières versions de la théorie du Big Bang,
l'univers a depuis continué à grandir
en ralentissant progressivement sous l'effet de la gravité.
Mais en 1998, des astronomes ont fait une surprenante découverte :
l'expansion de l'univers s'accélère.
L'univers grandit toujours plus, toujours plus vite,
à cause d'une mystérieuse force répulsive nommée énergie sombre.
Quand vous entendez « sombre » en physique,
soyez méfiants, car
cela signifie souvent que nous ne savons pas de quoi il s'agit.
(Rires)
On ne sait pas ce qu'est l'énergie sombre
mais la meilleure idée est qu'il s'agit de l'énergie de l'espace lui-même,
l'énergie du vide.
En utilisant la mécanique quantique
pour déterminer sa puissance,
le résultat est simplement ahurissant.
L'énergie sombre devrait être
10 exposant 120 fois plus puissante
que la valeur observée par les astronomes.
C'est un 1 suivi de 120 zéros.
Un nombre tellement énorme
qu'on ne peut même pas l'imaginer.
On dit souvent des grands nombres qu'ils sont astronomiques.
Mais celui-ci va encore plus loin.
Aucun nombre astronomique n'est aussi grand.
C'est 10 exposant 39 fois plus grand
que le nombre d'atomes dans tout l'univers.
Cette prédiction est donc fausse.
On l'appelle même la pire prédiction de la physique,
et ce n'est pas qu'une simple bizarrerie théorique.
Si l'énergie sombre était aussi puissante,
l'univers se serait désintégré,
les étoiles et les galaxies n'existeraient pas, et nous non plus.
La puissance de l'énergie sombre est donc
la seconde valeur dangereuse,
et elle exige une précision encore plus fine
que le champ de Higgs.
Mais contrairement à celui-ci, elle n'a aucune explication connue.
On espérait que l'harmonisation
de la relativité générale,
la théorie du grand univers,
et de la mécanique quantique, la théorie de l'univers microscopique,
nous donnerait une solution.
Einstein lui-même a passé la fin de sa vie
à tenter vainement d'unifier la physique,
et les physiciens ont continué cette quête après lui.
La théorie des cordes fait partie des idées les plus prometteuses,
son fondement étant que,
si l'on pouvait zoomer sur les particules fondamentales,
on ne verrait pas du tout des particules,
mais de fines cordes d'énergie en vibration,
chaque fréquence de vibration correspondant à une particule différente,
un peu comme les notes d'une guitare.
C'est donc un point de vue plutôt élégant, presque poétique,
mais avec un problème catastrophique.
La théorie des cordes n'est en fait pas une théorie
mais plusieurs théories.
En réalité, on a estimé
qu'il existe 10 exposant 500 versions différentes.
Chaque version décrirait un univers différent
doté de lois physiques différentes.
Pour certains, ce n'est donc pas de la science.
Car la théorie est impossible à réfuter.
D'autres ont pris une approche différente
en se disant que cet échec en apparence
est la grande force de la théorie des cordes.
Et si tous ces différents univers possibles
existaient réellement, quelque part,
au sein d'un grand multivers ?
On peut alors comprendre
pourquoi ces deux dangereuses valeurs sont si étrangement précises.
La plupart du temps,
l'énergie sombre est si puissante que l'univers se désintègre
ou le champ de Higgs est si faible qu'aucun atome ne se forme.
Nous sommes dans une partie du multivers
où les deux valeurs sont parfaites.
Un univers Boucles d'Or.
Cette idée est très controversée, ce qui est compréhensible.
En suivant cette réflexion, nous ne saurons jamais
capables de répondre à la question,
« Pourquoi y a-t-il quelque chose plutôt que rien ? »
La majorité du multivers est vide, il n'y a rien,
et nous sommes à l'un des rares endroits
où les lois de la physique permettent qu'il y ait quelque chose.
Pire encore, l'idée d'un multivers est impossible à tester.
Nous n'avons pas accès à ces autres univers,
et nous ne pouvons donc pas savoir s'ils existent ou non.
Nous sommes donc dans une situation extrêmement frustrante.
Cela ne prouve pas que le multivers n'existe pas.
Il y a bien d'autres planètes, étoiles, galaxies,
alors pourquoi pas d'autres univers ?
Malheureusement, nous ne le saurons probablement jamais.
L'idée du multivers circule depuis un certain temps,
mais ces dernières années ont offert les premiers indices concrets
qui pourraient confirmer ce raisonnement.
On attendait beaucoup des premières expériences au LHC,
nous espérions y trouver —
nous cherchions de nouvelles théories de physique :
supersymétrie ou nouvelles grandes dimensions,
quelque chose qui pourrait expliquer la valeur du champ de Higgs.
Malgré ces attentes, le LHC n'a révélé qu'un monde subatomique désert
à la seule exception du boson de Higgs.
Publication après publication,
nous avons dû nous rendre à l'évidence : il n'y a aucun signe de nouvelle physique.
Les enjeux présents sont donc énormes.
Cet été, le LHC a entamé la seconde phase des expériences
en doublant presque l'énergie de la première phase.
Les physiciens cherchent désespérément
de nouvelles particules, de minuscules trous noirs
ou peut-être autre chose d'inattendu
que les violentes collisions du LHC pourraient révéler.
Cela permettrait de continuer le long voyage
qui a commencé il y a 100 ans avec Albert Einstein
toujours plus loin à la découverte des lois de la nature.
Mais si dans deux ou trois ans,
quand le LHC sera désactivé pour une deuxième longue période,
nous n'avons trouvé que le boson de Higgs,
ce pourrait être le début d'une nouvelle ère de la physique,
une ère où l'univers a d'étranges propriétés inexplicables,
où nous suspectons qu'il existe un multivers
que nous ne pourrons malheureusement jamais atteindre,
où nous n'aurons jamais la réponse à la question
« Pourquoi y a-t-il quelque chose plutôt que rien ? »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Bruno Giussani : Harry, même si vous dites que
la science n'a pas réponse à tout,
j'aimerais vous poser quelques questions, dont celle-ci :
la construction du LHC est un projet intergénérationnel.
En vous présentant, j'ai souligné la vision à court terme du monde.
En construisant un tel projet,
comment vous projetez-vous si loin, au-delà de votre génération ?
Harry Cliff : J'ai la chance
d'avoir rejoint l'équipe où je travaille au LHC en 2008,
juste avant le lancement,
et certains parmi nous travaillent sur ce projet
depuis trente ans, depuis le début de leur carrière.
Je pense que l'idée du LHC a été lancée en 1976,
et il a fallu imaginer la machine sans la technologie
qui sera nécessaire pour la construire.
La conception a commencé au début des années 90,
sans les ordinateurs modernes.
On pensait qu'aucune technologie
ne pourrait supporter les radiations
que l'un des grands détecteurs aurait à subir,
et on a donc imaginé un gros bloc de plomb
entouré de quelques détecteurs,
mais la technologie fut ensuite créée.
Il faut donc compter sur notre capacité à résoudre les problèmes,
mais cela peut prendre 10 ans et plus encore.
BG : Il y a deux semaines, la Chine a annoncé
qu'elle compte construire
un collisionneur deux fois plus grand que le LHC.
J'aimerais savoir ce qu'en pensent les physiciens.
HC : La taille ne fait pas tout. BG : Je n'en doute pas.
(Rires)
C'est drôle qu'un physicien dise cela.
Mais blague à part, c'est génial.
Construire une machine comme le LHC
nécessite de réunir les ressources du monde entier.
Aucun pays ne peut s'offrir une telle machine,
sauf peut-être la Chine, car ils ont de grandes ressources,
de main-d'œuvre et d'argent pour construire ce genre de machines.
C'est donc une bonne chose.
Leur objectif est de construire une machine pour étudier
le boson de Higgs en détail et savoir si ces nouvelles idées,
comme la supersymétrie, sont réalisables,
c'est une bonne chose pour la physique, je pense.
BG : Harry, merci. HC : Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)